let's start today with a very meaty
substantial discussion about the
American economy inflation has reached
its lowest annual level in two years and
the right is coming up with new ways to
talk about how the economy is absolutely
terrible and that's the question we're
going to address with real numbers today
I recently reported to you on on Monday
in fact Monday of this week or three
months ago I don't remember no it was
two days ago I told you about the better
than expected jobs numbers that came out
of April during the Biden Administration
and I hesitate to give too much credit
or blame on these issues in general to
presidents because they have to do with
so many broader macroeconomic Trends but
everybody wants to make everything
political but let's not get ahead of
ourselves let's start with inflation and
then we'll move on from there
consumer prices in April rise at slowest
annual rate in two years reminder
often when we see the inflation numbers
from last month they are actually the
numbers for the 12-month period ending
last month so in may we get the April 22
to April 23 numbers in June we will get
the May 22 to May 23 numbers this is
like a trailing 12-month period consumer
prices in April this is uh Yahoo finance
consumer prices in April April showed
inflation pressures remain elevated
while headline Prices rose at the
slowest annual rate since the period
ending April 2021. according to the
latest data from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics the Consumer Price Index
revealed headline and inflation Rose 0.4
percent over the last month and 4.9
percent over the prior year in April Now
reminder inflation has been very high as
you can see here this is a chart uh
dating back to 1970 we had this period
uh culminating in uh June of 2022 where
inflation got very high uh as high as
it's been going all the way back to the
early 80s and then exactly as predicted
uncontroversially it has been declining
declining declining my prediction was
and there's nothing special about me I'm
not patting myself on the back I'm not
special in any way just the way things
were looking getting an Outlook of what
we were seeing uh you know in the used
car market in the grocery store in real
estate just looking a little bit being
reasonable adults most of us some
children in the audience my sense was by
the end of this year
we would be somewhere in the low fives
mid fours roughly when it comes to
inflation which is still historically a
little high but dramatically lower half
of where we uh reached so that's
happening and of course you will you're
already seeing right Wingers saying
David these numbers are obviously fake
have you seen the price of eggs lately
and of course it's not just driven by
the price of eggs this is a a measure
that we've talked about a number of
times it's composed of a number of
factors but let's now ask a broader
question if we look at all of those
different indicators that I often tell
you about to answer the question is the
economy doing well by traditional
measures which don't capture every
aspect of the economy but they give us a
picture what's going on with inflation
how is GDP where is unemployment how's
consumer confidence how's the stock
market doing what about trade balance
you get a picture that is quite
unremarkable in the sense of things are
pretty much okay
now does that mean we don't have
inequality no we do and we've had it for
a long time does this mean wages haven't
been keeping up with inflation
absolutely uh going back well beyond Joe
Biden but the picture is not a very
scary picture you look at GDP GDP in Q4
of 2022
was up 2.6 percent and in q1 of this
year was up 1.1 percent 1.1 percent
again this is annualized this isn't an
incredible number we look for two to
three percent but it's not a bad number
either we saw of course this is a chart
going back that includes the pandemic Q2
of 2020 we saw one of the largest GDP
decreases uh in in a very long time
we made a lot of that back in Q3 and
then the numbers have just sort of been
like okay at the beginning of 2022 we
actually saw some negative GDP growth
then more positive and Q3 and Q4 of last
year and then now a positive but not
explosively exciting number so GDP is
sort of like okay
you look at the unemployment rate and
you see of course this big spike here
this was the the heart of covid of the
pandemic and since then unemployment has
declined decline declined much of this
under President Joe Biden how much
credit we give him depends on who you
are but be that as it is you see that
the unemployment rate has now gotten
very low as low as it got under Trump as
low as it's been quite frankly dating
all the way back to the late 1960s so
unemployment is very low
huh doesn't look like a disaster we then
look at consumer confidence consumer
confidence is another indicator
representing the confidence of the
average person in the American economy
and you see that uh consumer confidence
did decline a little bit in April not
much but a little bit
um but it is historically at quite a
high level consumer confidence is a
little bit below where it was at the
height of the stock market rally while
Trump was president but it is
historically quite high and you the the
chart is on the screen and sort of the
numbers speak for themselves well what
about the stock market these are S P 500
returns going all the way back to 1930
as you can see this very clearly shows
the boom bust cycle of the American
economy and as you can see here we had
um 2022 last year a very bad year for
the stock market it 2021 was quite good
that was again a year under Joe Biden
the s p returning 27 in 2021 losing 19
in 2022 and so far this year the S P 500
has returned more than seven percent and
it's only May so really no major red
flag big scary data from the stock
market either things are pretty okay and
then lastly you look at the trade
balance which many uh folks on the right
often like to discuss important to
understand so trade balance means how
much are we exporting versus how much
are we importing the U.S has had
consistent trade deficits for a long
time this chart uh let's see if we can
go back further
um there we go so if you go back to the
mid 70s the U.S has had high trade
deficits and this is because we import a
bunch of oil and consumer products and
consumer products more recently oil has
not been the source of the trade deficit
that applies under Trump and Biden even
though Trump likes to pretend that it
was only under Trump that we weren't uh
having a deficit on oil but it's under
Biden as well and as you can see if we
look more recently since early 2022 the
trade deficit has been declining so
again a situation that is much bigger
than Biden but nothing hugely concerning
so what is the big picture with the
economy the big picture with the economy
is that stepping outside of the
political realm without assigning credit
or blame to Joe Biden or Kamala Harris
or Donald Trump or Mike Pence we just
take a 20-year View and we look at what
happened under Trump and what's been
happening on Biden and it is really
difficult to make the statistical case
that we are in a disastrous economy
today could a major recession be coming
of course that's a reality of the type
of capitalist economy in which we live
that was true under Bush Obama Trump and
Biden but are we in a disastrously
perilous place right now that we can
point to when it comes to any of these
indicators the answer is no
fired Fox News propaganda's Tucker
Carlson is coming back he is relaunching
his show
on Twitter what the hell would Twitter
what does that make any I don't know
here is Tucker Carlson's announcement
now viewed nearly 20 million times he
made the announcement on Twitter I guess
partnering with Elon Musk to relaunch
telling a number of corrosive lies let's
take a look at Tucker's big announcement
filmed in Ultra wide screen they've
never seen widescreen this wide
um apparently from his cabin in Maine or
Florida who knows let's take a listen
hey it's Tucker Carlson you often hear
people say the news is full of lies but
most of the time that's not exactly
right much of what you see on television
or read the New York Times is in fact
true in the literal sense it could pass
one of the media's own fact checks
lawyers would be willing to sign off on
it in fact they may have but that
doesn't make it true it's not true at
the most basic level the news you
consume is a lie a lie of the
stealthiest and most Insidious kind
facts have been withheld on purpose
along with proportion and perspective
you are being manipulated how does that
work let's see if I tell you that a man
has been unjustly arrested for armed
robbery that is not strictly speaking a
lie he may have been framed at this
point there's been no trial so no one
can really say
but if I don't mention the fact that the
same man has been arrested for the same
crime six times before am I really
informing you no I'm not I'm misleading
you and that's what the news media are
doing and what's really funny about this
is that it's a very fair criticism
of the way that Fox News including
Tucker Carlson present news stories and
have done so since they launched in what
it was in 1996 or 1997. it's quite I
mean he's right about everything he's
saying the problem is he's as guilty as
anyone of exactly what he's calling out
here every story that matters every day
of the week every week of the year
what's it like to work in a system like
that after more than 30 years in the
middle of it we could tell you stories
what a victim huh what a poor guy the
best you can hope for in the news
business at this point is the freedom to
tell the fullest truth that you can but
there are always limits and you know
that if you bump up against those limits
often enough you will be fired for it so
now Tucker is arguing he was fired for
bumping up against the limits valiantly
and bravely trying to tell us the truth
but I guess someone didn't really want
him to do that or something I mean this
you could only believe this if you
followed absolutely nothing of what's
been going on with Tucker Carlson for
the last decade that's not a guess it's
guaranteed every person who works in
English language media understands that
the rule of what you can't say defines
everything it's filthy really right and
it's utterly corrupting you can't have a
free Society if people aren't allowed to
say what they think is true speech is
the fundamental prerequisite for
democracy that's why it's enshrined in
the first of our constitutional
amendments amazingly as of tonight there
aren't many platforms left that allow
free speed there aren't that's
surprising to many people last a big one
remaining in the world the only one is
Twitter how convenient we are now wow
Twitter has long served as the place
where our national conversation
incubates and develops Twitter is not a
partisan site everybody's allowed here
and we think that's a good thing
and yet for them who's this we by the
way most part the news that you see
analyzed on Twitter comes from media
organizations that are themselves thinly
disguised propaganda Outlets like Fox
you see it on cable news you talk about
it on Twitter
the result may feel like a debate but
actually The Gatekeepers are still in
charge
we think that's a bad system we know
exactly how it works and we're sick of
it starting soon we'll be bringing a new
version of the show we've been doing for
the last six and a half years to Twitter
we bring some other things too which
we'll tell you about but for now we're
just grateful to be here free speech is
the main right that you have without it
you have no others see you soon there
you go so Tucker Carlson bravely
announcing that he will be coming to
Twitter now I will mention that Elon
Musk in response to this uh tweeted
um I want to be clear we have not signed
a deal of any kind whatsoever Tucker is
subject to the same rules and rewards of
all content creators rewards means
subscriptions and AD Revenue share still
working on software needed for ladder
which is a function of how many people
subscribe and the ad views associated
with the content I hope that many others
particularly from the left also choose
to be content creators on this platform
listen I'd love to learn more about that
I we we've never been there's never been
ad Revenue available to us that we've
been aware of on Twitter which is
interesting I'd like to learn more so
listen this is Tucker's big return
I don't know to what extent this is the
most profitable Avenue for him I I just
don't know I need to learn a little more
about it uh but it it is very clear that
this is the continued uh refrain from
the right that pre-elon musk Twitter was
not for free speech it was not a
so-called Free Speech platform the
speech of conservatives was unfairly
limited but now we can all rejoice and
pray at the altar of Elon Musk because
he has saved Twitter made it a free
speech platform once again now when you
look at that algorithmic for you feed on
Twitter you very quickly realize that it
has overwhelmingly become a platform
that feeds you right-wing dribble uh
from some of the folks I mentioned when
we talked about this on the Lex Friedman
podcast including Bridget Gabriel and
others for some reason I always have
shown her stuff even though I don't
follow her so this is Tucker's big
announcement I'm interested did from a
media critique perspective of seeing how
it goes I'm interested in seeing whether
people do shows on Twitter which is sort
of A New Concept and we're going to
follow it make sure you're subscribed on
the platforms that uh we have not
um abandoned uh at this point in time
which include of course YouTube Tick
Tock Snapchat and many many others we'll
take a quick break and be back right
after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
well we woke up to some delightful news
this morning lying disgraced Republican
Congressman George Santos also known to
many as George Anthony devolder Santos
George devolder Anthony devolder Anthony
Santos and all I think that covers most
of the permutations
he has been arrested and is in federal
custody as we speak charged with 13
different criminal counts isn't this
fantastic news and we'll talk about the
Trump 5 million dollar verdict in a
moment
um
what will happen to George Santos now
that he has been arrested maybe this
will get him uh out of Congress which
would be delightful CNN reports George
Santos in federal custody as fed feds
unseal a 13-count indictment we have a
mug shot it's an incredible thing the
justice department Wednesday unsealed
federal charges against Congressman
George Santos and the New York
Republican is in custody is in custody
Santos whose astonishing pattern of lies
and Fabrication stunned even hardened
politicos has been charged on a 13-count
indictment including seven counts of
wire fraud three counts of money
laundering one count of theft of public
funds and two counts of making material
materially false statements to the House
of Representatives this is just a
delight he was taken into custody in
Melville on Long Island where the FBI is
housed from there he was taken to a
courthouse in Central Islip
he's expected to appear later today in
federal court may already happen by the
time you listen to Today's show or watch
the congressman's attorney declined to
comment to CNN spokespeople for the
Brooklyn U.S attorney's Office justice
department and FBI also declined to
comment one of my favorite things is
that he seemed not to even like know
what was going on when it was first
mentioned to him he's like this is news
to me Santos was enroute back to New
York Tuesday night skipping house votes
for the evening according to a source a
spokeswoman for Santos NASA woomer
wouldn't respond to questions shouted
from reporters yesterday abruptly
Departed the congressman's office with a
backpack prior to her departure from the
office CNN witnessed three staffers
abruptly depart with their bags they
wouldn't talk can you imagine you're
working for like the biggest liar in
Congress and now he's arrested it's it's
just a delight a house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy said he's going to look at the
charges before determining whether
Santos should be removed from Congress
quote I'll look at the charges he said
to CNN
Santos was spotted in the capital
earlier yesterday on his way in and out
of McCarthy's office the speaker said he
didn't know why Santos was even there
and that the congressman had not told
him personally about the charges as you
know during his brief time in office
Santos was accused of breaking campaign
Finance laws violating Federal conflict
of interest laws stealing cash meant for
an Iraq war Veteran's dying dog
masterminding a credit card fraud scheme
and lying about where he went to school
and where he worked and I would add to
that lying about his athletic
achievements and lying about so many
different things this is this is really
great and it's not great as some on the
right will say because I just want my
political enemies to have weaponized uh
justice proceedings against them when
there is no evidence they've done
anything wrong it's it's actually quite
the opposite there is so much material
about the wrongdoing of George Santos
including all sorts of different
criminality what's good is that he's
being held accountable he's not being
excused from wrongdoing because he is
one of 435 members of Congress members
of the House of Representatives better
said one of 535 members of of both
houses of Congress that's good when
people are held accountable that's a
good thing the Associated Press
reporting about this as well there's one
particular moment that I love
um this is so good reached on Tuesday
Santos said this is news to me the AP
called him to say hey what do you think
about all the charges and your
forthcoming arrest he was like news to
me I don't know anything about it he
said in a brief phone interview you're
the first to call me about it
that is just just absolutely the best so
we're going to follow this very closely
there are two stories here there is the
story of the charges and the wrongdoing
itself on the one hand and then there is
the story of what do Republicans do many
Republicans have wanted this guy out for
a while but it wasn't really clear they
had the whole party behind them and so
they kind of said listen we have a
process I don't know if we really have
the votes or whatever and they kind of
shut up about it and it to a degree it
went away
um you then had other Republicans who
very much want to get this guy out it
wasn't clear they had a path to do it
before these charges maybe now they do
it's important to remember charges are
merely allegations in the United States
you're innocent until proven guilty in a
court of law however there are many jobs
where if you are charged with certain
crimes you are at minimum suspended from
your job
and then if you are in the future
acquitted then there are different
processes again it's different depending
on the military would be one thing
financial services companies to have
other policies so on and so forth there
is latitude from employers of different
kinds as to how charges are handled
given that charges themselves are not
actually guilty verdicts and that's the
system we have and that's a good thing
what do Republicans do now I don't know
but we'll be watching it and delightful
news to wake up to Donald Trump has been
found liable of sexual abuse and
defamation of e Gene Carroll he has not
been found liable when it comes to rape
why am I using the term liable I'm using
the term liable because this is a civil
lawsuit and Trump indeed these are not
criminal charges Trump will uh it has
been ordered to pay 5 million dollars in
Damages this is a major story we've been
following for some time e Gene Carroll a
writer alleges that alleged and alleges
that Donald Trump sexually assaulted and
raped her in the Bergdorf Goodman
Department Store in Manhattan in New
York City in the 90s the reason uh let
me even before I go further Donald Trump
in denying those accusations uh insulted
her in a number of different ways due to
a special provision that allows you to
bring a civil suit in cases of sexual
assault even when the criminal aspect
has passed its statute of limitations e
Gene Carroll was able to sue Trump
civilly in New York both for sexual
assault and for defamation and she has
prevailed we can say CNN reports a
Manhattan Federal jury found that Donald
Trump sexually abused e Gene Carroll in
a luxury department store dressing room
in the spring of 1996 and awarded her 5
million dollars for battery and
defamation
Carol alleged Trump raped her in the
Bergdorf Goodman Department Store and
then defamed her when he denied her
claim saying she's not his type and
suggested she made up the story to boost
Book Sales Trump denied all wrongdoing
he does not face jail time as a result
of the Civil verdict while the jury did
find that Trump sexually abused her
sufficient to hold him liable for
battery the jury did not find that Carol
proved he raped her so there's a bunch
of different stories that are going on
here one of the stories is Trump's
lawyer and other maggots saying Trump
prevailed
he was not found liable for rape that's
one perspective the other perspective is
Trump did not Prevail he's been ordered
to pay five million dollars for sexual
assault
and for defamation and he certainly did
not Prevail the other perspective and
we'll look at Trump's response is that
this is all just the same politically
organized weaponization of law
enforcement
that they've been saying now for years
uh there's no evidence of that
whatsoever everything here was handled
based on every lawyer I spoke to this
morning everything was handled perfectly
by the judge despite Trump's allegations
that the judge has it out for Trump in
some way now there is the belief that
there will be an appeal here Trump's
lawyer takapina I forget is it Joe
takapina
um said that they will appeal and uh
again restated that Trump prevailed in
the sense that he was not found liable
for rape but the outcome is still quite
bad for Trump Will trump pay the 5
million dollars well we don't know
certainly not before any relevant
appeals have concluded that we can be
sure of if Trump ultimately does pay
maybe he can do some of the things he's
done in the past like maybe reroute five
million dollars in I don't know campaign
donations to pay for this or something
along those lines the Maga people
already dismissing this as a listen it's
simply a civil case this isn't Criminal
it's no big deal as if suddenly civil
cases are completely irrelevant but of
course we know that that's not the case
after the break we are going to look at
the complete crumbling of trump in
response to this as well as a former
Trump White House staffer coming forward
and saying there were countless
allegations of sexual harassment against
Trump while he was President of the
United States forget about the dozens of
allegations against Trump before he
became president it turns out that there
are dozens of allegations against Trump
while he was in the white house we we
just learned about this in the last 24
hours incredible incred but not
surprising
we will talk about that after the break
if you value what we do at the
Department Show remember to support us
on patreon go to patreon.com
davidpackman show where you can get
access to behind the scenes videos The
Daily bonus show the commercial free
Daily Show as well as special discounts
on merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpackman show the
failed former president Donald Trump
exploded on his platform truth Central
after a jury found him liable for sexual
assault and defamation of e Gene Carroll
in that Bergdorf Goodman Department
Store in Manhattan in the 1990s you knew
he was going to absolutely lose his mind
let's take a look at the various
uncontrollable posts uh sort of like
diarrhea of the post rather than the
mouth right before the decision was made
Trump troll thing quote waiting for a
jury decision on a quote on a capital f
false accusation where I despite being a
current political candidate and leading
all others in both parties am not
allowed to speak or defend myself now
that's a lie Trump could have testified
in fact he said he was flying back to
the U.S to testify his lawyers were like
no you're not dude you're not doing that
um saying even as hard-nosed reporters
scream questions about this case at me
in the meantime the other side has a
book falsely accusing me of capital r
rape and is working with the Press I
will therefore not speak until after the
trial but will appeal the capital u
unconstitutional silencing of me as a
candidate no matter the outcome now
remember while he was President E Gene
Carroll wanting to have these
allegations adjudicated wasn't fair
because Trump was a sitting president
now that Trump's no longer a president
the whole trial is unfair because he's a
candidate
endless then we got the decision and
that's when Trump turned on caps lock
and really went in for the crazy Trump
posting after the verdict quote I have
absolutely no idea who this woman is
this verdict is a disgrace a
continuation of the greatest Witch Hunt
of all time then trophing again in all
capital letters very unfair trial and
then the video started Trump using truth
Central almost like a short form like
Tick Tock a short form Vlog platform
posting these 15 and 20 second videos
let's take a look at the first one here
Trump putting on his suit and tie and
standing in front of flags in order to
deliver these unhinged statements if you
can imagine this was a very unfair trial
that's all you have to say this was a
very unfair trial right and there that's
the that's the full statement from Trump
in that particular video then he wrote
and it's funny it says it's a 15 second
video but because of like the the little
closing uh animation it's really only
like a seven second video Trump then
posting a 21 second video I have
absolutely no idea who this woman is the
verdict is a disgrace a continuation of
the greatest Witch Hunt of all time
absolutely a shame
so that's Trump reading the truth that I
mentioned to you earlier I guess they
just put it up on the on the
teleprompter maybe that's why it's in
all caps to make it easier for Trump to
read I don't know it's all very strange
and then Trump putting out a slightly
lengthier Vlog about this what else can
you expect from a trump hating
clinton-appointed judge who went out of
his way to make sure that the result
of this trial was as negative as it
could possibly be now there's no
evidence that any of this is true every
lawyer I spoke to this morning said that
the judge handled the case perfectly
fine speaking to and in control of a
jury from an anti-trump area which is
probably the worst place in the United
States for me to get a fair trial
we'll be appealing this decision it's a
disgrace I don't even know who this
woman is I have no idea who she is where
she came from this is another scam I'm
finding this a little difficult to
believe to be perfectly honest with you
it's a political Witch Hunt and somehow
we're gonna have to fight this stuff we
cannot let our country go into this
Abyss this is disgraceful you have
somebody running for office you have a
woman that's financed and lied about it
she totally lied about it by Democrat
operatives like just about the biggest
one there is
and she said that wasn't true they found
that she lied about it isn't this
incredibly whiny and the judge wasn't
even I guess letting it be put in as
evidence huh the whole thing is a scam
and it's a shame and it's a disgrace to
our country there you go
very powerful statement from Donald
Trump so listen
um we've got Trump who has now been
arrested and charged in New York found
civilly liable in New York likely to be
arrested and charged again in Georgia
sometime between I'm trying to remember
the dates we heard from Fannie Willis
down in Georgia I believe it was between
July 11th and September 1st or something
like that where they they have this next
charging period where grand jury
decisions will be made and charging
decisions will be made this is not going
very well for Donald Trump but I have to
hand it to the Maga people his support
among the Republican party is only going
up and so it still appears
that this is very much not good for
Trump in terms of the general election
although he still could win you look at
the polling it's close but it is it is
actually quite good for Trump in the
Republican primary and in some way it's
some indirect way
Trump's charges and the 5 million dollar
liability finding and how all of this
stuff it may be desantises undoing
because it's actually boosting Trump now
Trump has a town hall tonight on CNN
uh we're going to talk about that later
uh and they damn well damn well better
ask about this stuff but I don't I don't
know that it will we'll get to that a
little bit later
in the wake of the finding by a New York
jury that Donald Trump is liable for
sexual assault and defamation against
writer E Gene Carroll in that Bergdorf
Goodman Department Store in New York
City in the 1990s we now have a Cascade
of Serial sexual harassment allegations
against Donald Trump
from a former staffer while he was
President of the United States there was
maybe the the belief I don't know I mean
you know sometimes it's like these
serial harassers and assaulters
they don't often stop particularly not
when they're in positions of power but
there were dozens of allegations of
different levels of sexual assault
against Trump from sort of like verbal
harassment all the way up to rape
dozens of them in periods of time before
Donald Trump became president of the
United States a former staffer is now
accusing Trump of sexual harassment in
the White House Newsweek reports
staffers who worked in Trump's White
House have accused him of sexual
harassment
the uh okay so a lot of this news is
about the verdict which we've already
talked about and Trump's reaction
discussing the verdict on CNN Alyssa
Farah Griffin who quit as Trump's White
House comes director in December of 2020
said Trump had a pattern of Behaving
inappropriately with women while in the
white house she noted she wasn't the
only one to report such Behavior to
Trump's Chief of Staff take a look at
this clip from CNN stunning but not
altogether surprising listen when Donald
Trump tells you who he is believe him um
I mean that is this is it we wanted to
chalk it up to locker room talk in 2016.
it was not locker room talk now he is
credibly he has been he's now been
charged with or I should say held liable
in this case for actually committing
sexual assault like I cannot underscore
that enough that your guest before made
an incredibly important Point any man or
woman who was falsely accused would be
the first person to show up and to
defend themselves in a rape allegation
or a sexual assault allegation he
couldn't be bothered to show up I have
countless cases of what I considered
impropriety in the white house that I
brought to the chief of staff because I
thought the way he engaged with women
was dangerous this is I mean we know
these facts the patterns have laid out
and now this is something that's not
just speculation it's not just
allegations it is a jury of his peers
deciding that he did this wait you
brought to Mark Meadows the chief of
staff uh or other Chiefs of Staff
incidents that you witnessed of Donald
Trump behaving in inappropriately with
women I did as well as a former White
House Press Secretary Stephanie Grisham
and others
um nothing that rises to this level but
things that I would consider improper
and that I had a duty to report and this
is all out there voters need to pay
attention and folks in my own party need
to stop making apologies for this man is
there anything more you can tell us
about this
I I if I'm able to I will share more all
right you have to come on this show to
tell it though those are major major
allegations now I want to zoom out a
little bit
the broader story with these major
allegations against Trump follows this
pattern
we hear one allegation
and Maga rallies around Trump and most
Republicans do and say it's made up and
then we get more allegations that now
start to become a pattern and it becomes
much more difficult to say that it's
made up I'll give you an example
Cassidy Hutchinson testified to the
January 6th committee when Democrats
still controlled the house before
January of this year Cassidy Hutchinson
testified
Trump lunged at a secret service agent
and demanded that he be brought I don't
even remember where it was where his the
rioters were whatever
and the reaction was that's so out of
character for Trump trump would never do
that Trump doesn't have a temper no it's
all it's all very clearly made up and
then a couple of weeks ago we get yet
another story
recent one which we have on a recording
which is Trump lunged at a reporter on
his plane because the reporter was
asking Trump what questions that Trump
did not want to answer and Trump
snatched the guy's phone out of his hand
and tossed it oh so it's the exact same
pattern of lunging at people when they
are talking to you about something you
don't want to talk about or telling you
something that you don't want to hear
it starts to become more and more
difficult to deny these things
particularly when they're recorded so
now we have another version of this
Trump sexually harassed one two 25 30 40
women before Trump became president it's
all fake it's totally out of character
okay we now have a court finding a jury
has found Trump is liable for sexual
assault and then defaming the woman who
accused him of the sexual assault he
owes her five million dollars oh well
that's also BS and now a former staffer
says oh by the way the exact same
pattern that e Gene Carroll alleged from
the 1990s dozens of other women alleged
during the 2000s it didn't stop when
Trump was in the white house it's all
the same story and so the right the Maga
right some Republicans who continue to
defend this this guy will insist these
are just these allegations are so hard
to believe they're just so Random
they're being made up they're being
weaponized these allegations of Trump's
temper Trump's snapping at people
lunging at people sexually harassing
sexually assaulting and going beyond
that with women
it's a decades-long pattern it's a
decades-long pattern that goes back
one of Trump's former wives I now forget
which one I think it was Ivana said
Trump sexually assaulted her multiple
times how can it all be this concerted
effort to defame Trump when first a jury
quite literally found that it was
actually Trump who did the defamation
and it's the same stories from women who
don't even know each other who have
nothing to do Alyssa Farah Griffin and
what she observed when she worked for
Trump
a few years ago has nothing to do with
what happened to Eugene Carroll or what
Trump's ex-wife alleged or what you know
the young women from the Miss whatever
pageant where Trump would go backstage
it's all unrelated individuals who don't
know each other and the pattern that's
emerging is these stories seem to be
corroborated again and again and again
from unrelated sources that's really the
Revelation here so tonight there's a
town hall on CNN
is it going to be handled responsibly is
it going to be handled the way it should
be handled given the insanity of who
Trump is and has become I'm not
confident but we're going to talk about
that after the break make sure make sure
you subscribe to the YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show make
sure you're following us on Tick Tock
for the short form content and make sure
you've signed up at joinpakman.com
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
CNN is holding a town hall event tonight
for Donald Trump in Saint Anselm at
Saint Anselm College in New Hampshire
this was already a very high stakes
media event in the sense that this is
not a normal person this is not I don't
know you know uh sununu's running and
we're going to do a town hall or
whatever the case may be Mitt Romney you
know this is uh one of the most
destructive forces to ever hold the
White House who was impeached twice has
been arrested and charged was just found
liable of sexual assault and defamation
and owes e Gene Carroll five million
dollars incited an Insurrection to try
to remain in the White House despite
having lost an election which to this
day he claims he actually won
this is not a normal person and so from
a media ratings and profit perspective I
understand why CNN is giving Trump a
town hall I get it I don't yet want to
pass judgment as to whether it will be a
responsible or irresponsible thing to do
because I want to see how CNN handles it
at this point in time
how do you not bring up
the sexual assault decision from that
jury how do you not bring up January 6th
how do you not bring up the arrest and
the likely additional forthcoming arrest
in Georgia that we expect to happen
sometime between July and August
are they going to handle this
responsibly or is it going to be
Mr Trump what will you do to stop Biden
Marxism if you were to get another term
in office right if it's that okay if
it's if that's the type of thing we're
going to see this may be one of the most
irresponsible media events that we ever
uh witnessed now which of the two is it
going to be I don't know the Associated
Press CNN's town hall with Trump takes
on higher Stakes after sexual abuse
verdict Trump will return to CNN's
Airwaves Wednesday joining the network
for a two-hour Town Hall event in early
voting New Hampshire a day after a civil
jury found him liable for sexually
assaulting an advice columnist nearly
three decades ago
The Forum which was announced last week
was expected to be notable because it
would be bringing together a network and
a candidate who have sparred with each
other but the stakes raised considerably
Tuesday after jurors in New York found
Trump sexually abused into famed Jean
Carroll though it rejected her claim
that he raped her the jury awarded her
five million dollars in charges it also
returns Focus to questions over Trump's
treatment of women over the years yeah
raising the stakes for an event at which
he will be forced to respond to tough
questioning from host Caitlin Collins in
the audience well we don't know that
will it be tough questioning I don't
know
Carol is more than one more than a dozen
women one of more than a dozen women who
accuse Trump of sexual assault or
harassment I think the number is
actually closer to 50.
Trump has historically not reacted well
when pressed on stage about his behavior
toward women most notably during the
first debate in 2015 when he sparred
with Fox host Megan Kelly he later said
she had blood coming out of her whatever
when she was questioning him that was an
insane moment so uh I I am um sort of
maintaining an open mind or whatever you
would say and many of you have written
to me and said David you don't need to
keep an open mind what what CNN is going
to do is completely irresponsible it's
going to be nuts now let's address a
little bit about my plans for coverage
of this event my plan was to stream the
town hall live and then to do a sort of
retrospective on it on tomorrow's show
let's deal with two parts of that am I
going to do that and then morally what
do I think about the whole thing let's
actually start with the morally first
I believe that what CNN is going to do
tonight may be completely completely
immoral journalistically but it may not
I want to wait and see how it goes I
want to see how Caitlin Collins handles
it I want to see what sort of questions
are selected the entire thing
um
my plan to cover it live tonight and to
discuss it tomorrow you know a few
people wrote to me and said David you're
doing something just as bad as CNN no I
with peace and love I completely reject
that notion we do a program that is
heavily centered around media analysis
and media criticism whether I talk about
the fact that this event took place or
not it's taking place I have nothing to
do with the fact that it's taking place
and I want to cover it in order to
analyze how CNN handles the event okay
so I don't have you know the idea that
I'm doing the same thing CNN is doing by
talking about recovering the event I
reject it completely we do media
analysis we do media criticism here now
that being said am I actually going to
cover the event live tonight no and the
reason why is CNN our YouTube rep and
our twitch contact both and we have
nobody at Facebook but I'm gonna assume
it's the same thing
twitch and YouTube have told me CNN
plans to go really hard against anyone
who broadcasts that event live tonight
um they will shut you down they will
shut you down on YouTube they will shut
you down on Twitch and you know what I
believe it because CNN has done it
before so the plan for tonight is I'm
going to stream a pre-show we are going
to have
Clips interviews with people on the
ground there at Saint Anselm in New
Hampshire we're going to discuss the
context surrounding this event going
live at 7 30 PM Eastern the event starts
at 9pm I believe let me just verify that
Trump Town Hall New Hampshire May 10
start time it was scheduled for nine I
want to make sure that's the case CNN
says how to watch
um
oh it's 8 P.M okay so let's actually do
it differently it starts at 8pm I will
go live at 7 p.m Eastern we'll do an
hour pre-show and then we'll end the
stream and if you want to watch the
event you can go and watch it from 8 to
10 on an official platform CNN online or
whatever and if you don't want to watch
it then I will do a retrospective of it
tomorrow so that's our plan I will be
watching for do they actually bring
quote tough questions to Trump is Trump
held accountable is Trump treated as the
abnormal president that he was and and
the abnormal candidate that he that he
is or does CNN normalize him all
questions which we will find out answers
to tonight join me at 7 pm Eastern I
will see you then my pillow Mike Lindell
the CEO and founder of my pillow
is yet again saying he is about to blow
the roof off he's gonna blow your socks
off with his latest event the election
crimes Summit this is so hard to take
seriously at this point
the Springfield News Leader announces my
uh Mike pillow MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
my pillow CEO and prominent election
fraud theorist plans to return to
Springfield Missouri in August to host
an election crime Bureau Summit this
will be August 15 and 16. this is yet
another one of these events at which no
election crimes will be revealed that is
my sense here is Mike pillow with a very
difficult to believe prediction that
this will be the most show most watched
show in world history it's hard to take
it even at all seriously my friends uh
we've got the um
uh election crime Bureau that's going
great we've got the summit coming up
we're going to keep pushing that August
16th and 17th in Springfield Missouri is
going to be the biggest simultaneous or
the biggest uh Watch program I hope in
history because if you this will be
bigger than the mash finale we're going
to show everybody the plan going forward
we're going to say with all the evidence
over the last two years what we can do
with it what can we do with it even
though there that no judges are looking
at it what are we doing I love that
every judge is ignoring what we're
saying
but what can we do going beyond that
he's going to let you know that at this
event what can we do so that's going to
be really important yeah and um okay
it's stunning to me that Mike Lindell is
able to say these things with a straight
face is he ever going to drop this I
don't know now you might remember we
recently last week we interviewed uh Bob
seidman Robert zeidman he is the Cyber
guy
who um is now owed five million dollars
by Mike pillow because Bob zeidman an
admitted Trump supporter voted for Trump
twice
proved Mike pillow's claims wrong Mike
pillow didn't have evidence of a stolen
election in the United States and that
China was involved in it somehow and so
pillow now owns O's Bob zeidman five
million bucks
Zeidman's impression of pillow was that
he was serious about all of these claims
he's a True Believer here is Mike pillow
in this same interview on real America's
voice saying that he is not going to uh
go down uh quietly he's going to try to
not pay Bob the 5 million bucks take a
look at this uh everyone heard about the
five million dollar Fiasco that
challenged here challenging the uh the
evidence or some of the evidence that I
have and uh we're taking that top met
with the lawyers yesterday we're taking
that to court that's uh that's a report
on that there you go so he's going to be
appealing that have you seen a guy who
seems to love losing more than Mike
pillow he loses everything he told me
he's lost at months ago was 35 million
dollars related to all of this election
fraud nonsense he lost 5 million in the
finding with Bob zeidman he loses every
time he holds one of these symposia or
as he calls it the Symposium now it's
going to be a summit it may be easier to
pronounce for him he he just loses
everything there's no ratings no judges
are looking at any losing losing losing
and from all reports and this is said I
feel bad for the guy for this in the
sense that I feel bad for anybody who
starts to you know be alienated from
their family because of their their
I guess Insanity I don't know what else
to call it he seems to really be
struggling personally as a result of all
of this so he's welcome to come back on
the show anytime it's always interesting
to hear from him we had a perfectly
cordial conversation last time but uh
there is some level on which this is
truly very sad we have a voicemail
number that you can call if you'd like
to make your presence known that number
is
2192 David P here's a caller with a very
interesting question about Trump's fate
as a sex offender on the basis of the
finding against him in the E Gene
Carroll sexual assault and defamation
trial yesterday
David this is Alan calling from Texas
and I was just wondering will Donald
Trump be forced to register on the sex
offender website since he was convicted
of what was it sexual battery or assault
with the E Gene Carroll case
uh could you let us know thank you the
answer is no Trump will not have to
register as a sex offender so I checked
in with a couple lawyer friends today
and this was my instinct the sex
offender registry is for people found
criminally liable criminally liable and
um because Trump was found I'm sorry
criminally guilty because Trump was
found civilly liable as a civil judgment
a monetary judgment the standard of
proof is different and it does not
require registering as a sex offender
now it is true that sex offender
registration laws vary by state and
every lawyer I spoke to very lawyerly
said to me
generally speaking civil liability in
sexual assault does not confer State Sex
Offender Registry but it's possible
there's some state where the laws differ
because the laws on this stuff do differ
from state to state but I was not able
to find any state in which you were
required to register as a sex offender
if you're found civilly liable for
sexual assault
um it's it's usually pretty specific
it's you must register as a sex offender
if you are criminally convicted of
specific offenses usually rape is listed
sexual assault child molestation child
molestation you know child porn charges
are often in there Etc I know that
you're not supposed to call it child
porn but I think everybody knows what
I'm talking about the Civil judgment
question
theoretically could depend on state law
it appears as though States could
require that those found civilly liable
for similar actions
be required to register but the belief
of every attorney I spoke to today is
that there is no state that currently
has that requirement so Trump as far as
I know will not have to register as a
sex offender on the basis of this
finding we have such a great bonus show
for you today although many of the
stories are sort of sad stories and
disturbing stories
the gunman who killed eight at the Texas
shopping mall over the weekend we now
know
uh had Neo-Nazi ideation and Neo-Nazi
tattoos still this isn't stopping some
on the right from saying it was a setup
it was a false flag or whatever the case
may be
um of course there's no evidence of that
there's evidence that he was a Neo-Nazi
although police are still searching for
the specific motivation in going to that
mall on that day I think it's fair to
say he was a Neo-Nazi we don't yet
necessarily know the motivation although
we can speculate but let's try not to
speculate and go with what we know so
we're going to talk about that on the
bonus show today secondly
this seems to happen again and again and
again
one of these anti-grooming Crusaders
he's a republican of course from Texas
he has now resigned because of sexual
misconduct he was involved in with a
teenage staffer or aide I think they
call them
yet again
yet again and lastly the subway crime
debate has been revived in New York City
because of this horrible choking death
that took place I have so much
experience with the New York subway and
I've seen it change to some degree over
the years I will weigh in with my
experiences on the subway as well as a
white looking guy right I think it's
fair to say sure I'm a Hispanic
immigrant from Argentina but I present
like a white guy a boring white guy
um and I know that that may be a factor
in my experiences versus the experiences
of others on the New York subway so
we'll talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show please
sign up for the bonus show folks it
really is great oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad yeah okay I mean we do make money on
the bonus show but it also it really is
great and we'll talk about all of these
stories today you can sign up at
joinpakman.com
I believe our normal membership rates
are so reasonable so reasonable but if
you'd like a discount
it's not means tested it's available to
whoever wants it use the coupon code
indicted and you'll save roughly 50 all
right everybody see you in a few on the
bonus show we're back here tomorrow
foreign